J'aimerais pouvoir me présenter, mais je suis
mort, c'est un peu dommage, c'est mon
meilleur ami,
nous avons même presque des conversations,
parfois hmm, appelez ces gars à genoux,
ils mangeront n'importe quoi avec un battement de cœur.
je suis en
conflit à ce propos
il
change et il se sent et il réapprend à
être humain oh mon Dieu ouais
alors a commencé quelque chose que ce soit que
vous aviez tous les deux ça infecte les autres
papa il se guérit d'une manière ou d'une autre ils
ne se guérissent pas
viennent avec moi
tirer à vue la branche me garde
changer tout ce que nous voyons des cadavres mon pote
squelette monsieur
c'est une reprise de tir que salut
alors est-il votre petit ami garçon zombie abattu